antes de ver las propiedades físicas de
los aldehídos y las entones quiero que
veamos de dónde salieron los nombres de
estos grupos funcionales una forma de
hacer aldehídos y cetonas es oxidando un
alcohol así es que si empezamos aquí en
la izquierda con un metanol y lo
oxidamos obtenemos aquí un metan al
también llamado formaldehído y si
analizamos los átomos de estas dos
moléculas aquí tenemos un carbono por
aquí también tenemos un carbono
tenemos un oxígeno y aquí tenemos un
oxígeno pero aquí tenemos cuatro
hidrógenos mientras que aquí tenemos
únicamente dos hidrógenos así es que la
pérdida de dos hidrógenos puede hacer
que un metanol se convierta en un metal
y el nombre de aldehído tiene que ver
con eso si escribimos las palabras en
latín
alcohol de libros yen atún de iu
pero hice
y tú entonces tenemos aquí el nombre
aldehído porque tomamos el a el del
alcohol y después aquí tomamos de iu y
agregamos una o al final y bueno también
cambiamos esta y por una y latina y
listo tenemos al leído y también podemos
hacer de tonás si óxido este alcohol de
la izquierda este alcohol propanol
también llamado isopropanol o hizo
propio alcohol si óxido esta molécula
obtenemos esta otra molécula de aquí que
tiene 123 carbonos entonces se llama
propano net pero por supuesto nadie le
dice así porque ésta es una molécula muy
famosa
esta es la acetona
sí
zona y bueno aquí ya podemos ver por qué
se llaman cetonas y bueno aceptó net
proviene de una palabra alemana antigua
qué
pero bueno aquí podemos ver muy bien por
qué les llamamos cetonas bueno esto fue
un vistazo rápido a los nombres de estos
grupos funcionales que me parece muy
interesante pero ahora sí vamos a
empezar con las propiedades físicas y
vamos a utilizar estas últimas dos
moléculas para describir los puntos de
ebullición de ha leído si se tomas
aunque tomamos el 2 propanol de aquí en
la izquierda y vamos a comparar su punto
de ebullición con el punto de ebullición
de la acetona y cuando estamos hablando
acerca de puntos de ebullición
necesitamos pensar en las fuerzas
internos leku lares y las fuerzas que
hay entre dos moléculas así es que vamos
a dibujar dos moléculas de isopropanol
aquí
tenemos aquí un isopropanol y el oxígeno
es mucho más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno por lo que los electrones de
este enlace van a estar mucho más cerca
del oxígeno dándole una carga parcial
negativa al oxígeno y una carga parcial
positiva al hidrógeno y si tenemos por
aquí otra molécula isopropanol vamos a
dibujarla por aquí esta molécula se
encuentra en la misma situación el
oxígeno tiene una carga parcial negativa
y el hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva y sabemos qué cargas opuestos
se atraen entonces esta carga positiva
se atrae con esta carga negativa y esta
fuerza inter molecular se llama enlace
de puente de hidrógeno fuente de
hidrógeno ok
este es un ejemplo de un puente de
hidrógeno que sabemos que sucede entre
un hidrógeno y algún átomo muy electro
negativo
como el flúor el oxígeno o el nitrógeno
y además este hidrógeno también tiene
que estar enlazado con otro átomo que
sea también súper electro negativo como
el flúor oxígeno nitrógeno entonces este
es un ejemplo de un puente de hidrógeno
el cual es el tipo más fuerte de las
fuerzas intermuscular es entonces para
separar este puente de hidrógeno para
separar a estas dos moléculas se
necesita muchísima energía por lo cual
se necesita mucho calor y por eso tiene
un punto de ebullición bastante alto que
tiene un punto de ebullición de
aproximadamente 83 grados celsius bueno
ahora vamos a comparar esta situación
con la situación que se presenta con la
acetona entonces tenemos por aquí una
acepto na
si nos fijamos en este oxígeno y este
carbono este oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono por lo cual va a
jalar la nube de electrones y entonces
este oxígeno va a obtener una carga
parcial negativa y este carbono de aquí
va a obtener una carga parcial positiva
y entonces tenemos una situación de un
dipolo y por lo que esta molécula tiene
un momento dipolar y si tenemos por aquí
otra molécula de acetona pues tiene
exactamente la misma situación el
oxígeno tiene una carga parcial negativa
y el carbono tiene una carga parcial
positiva por los supuestos se atraen
entonces aquí tenemos otra interacción
inter molecular esta molécula también es
un di polo así es que a esto le llamamos
interacción dipolo dipolo de hecho los
puentes de hidrógeno son un ejemplo de
un enlace dipolo dipolo
y fuerte pero en general el resto de las
interacciones de polo de polio no son
tan fuertes como los puentes de
hidrógeno así es que las moléculas de
acepto no se atraen tanto como las
moléculas de isopropanol y por lo tanto
no se necesita tanta energía para
separarlas
así es que su punto de ebullición es más
bajo y de hecho el punto de ebullición
de la acetona es de 56 grados celsius
más o menos a ambos puntos de ebullición
son más altos que la temperatura
ambiente aunque entonces la temperatura
y presión ambiente el isopropanol y la
acetona son líquidos bueno ahora vamos a
ver otras moléculas
por aquí tenemos el propano tenemos
puras moléculas con tres carbono por
aquí tenemos un simple propano que tiene
un punto de ebullición de menos 42
grados celsius menos 42 grados celsius
está muy por debajo de la temperatura
ambiente la temperatura ambiente está
más o menos entre 20 y 25 grados celsius
entonces como su punto de ebullición es
más bajo que la temperatura ambiente el
propano generalmente lo encontramos como
un gas y si nos ponemos a pensar en las
fuerzas internos le cular es la única
fuerza inter molecular que mantiene
unidos a los cercanos son las fuerzas de
dispersión del london ok fuerza de bilis
john d
london
ok por aquí tenemos 3 carbonos 1 2 3 y
es una aldea ido entonces esta molécula
es un pro panel que tiene un punto de
ebullición de aproximadamente 50 grados
celsius y 50 grados celsius
definitivamente es mayor que la
temperatura ambiente entonces
generalmente encontramos al pro panel en
un estado líquido y aquí tenemos otra
vez a nuestro acetona que estábamos
viendo hace poco que tiene un punto de
ebullición de 56 grados celsius y estas
dos moléculas este aldehído y éstas etón
a los dos tienen interacciones dipolo
dipolo ok porque tienen una carga
parcial negativa en el oxígeno y una
carga parcial positiva en el carbono
entonces tienen una fuerza inter
molecular dipolo de polo a polo al que
nos tienen la fuerza de dispersión de
london y los aldehídos y la secc tonás
tiene la interacción de polo dipolo y
por aquí tenemos a un alcohol tenemos a
un 1 propanol en lugar del 2 propanol
que vimos el inicio del vídeo gay el 1
propanol tiene un punto de ebullición de
aproximadamente 97 grados celsius y la
fuerza interno le cooler que tiene son
los puentes de hidrógeno fuentes de
hidrógeno hidrógeno y aquí podemos ver
como el punto de ebullición refleja que
tan fuertes son las fuerzas de
interacción inter molecular ok los
puentes de hidrógeno son una fuerza
inter molecular mucho más fuerte que la
interacción dipolo dipolo y como podemos
ver en
de ebullición de los alcoholes es más
alto que el punto de ebullición de los
aldehídos y las cetonas y los aldehídos
y la acetona tienen un punto de
ebullición más alto que el de los
cercanos porque su fuerza de interacción
inter molecular dipolo dipolo es más
fuerte que la fuerza de dispersión de
london bueno ya vimos todo lo que
necesitábamos ver acerca del punto de
ebullición ahora
lo que vamos a ver es la solubilidad en
agua aunque tan solubles son algunas
moléculas en el agua
sólo billy
dado y nuevamente vamos a utilizar a la
acetona entonces tenemos por aquí
nuestra molécula de aceptó no podemos
buscar los pares de electrones libres
del oxígeno y sabemos que el oxígeno
tiene una carga parcial negativa y este
carbono del grupo carbón y lo tiene una
carga parcial positiva tenemos aquí una
molécula polarizada y como estamos
viendo la solubilidad en agua entonces
tenemos que dibujar por aquí nuestra
molécula de agua y bueno las moléculas
de agua también están polarizadas los
electrones de este enlace esta nube de
electrones se queda siempre más cerca
del oxígeno porque es más electro
negativo entonces el oxígeno tiene una
carga parcial negativa y el hidrógeno
tiene una carga parcial positiva polos
opuestos se atraen y aquí tenemos una
interacción inter molecular y podemos
reconocer muy rápidamente
trata de un puente de hidrógeno fuente
de hidrógeno y entonces ahora sabemos
que la acetona se puede disolver en agua
por estos puentes de hidrógeno porque
las moléculas polares si se disuelven en
medios polares ahora se me olvidó
explicar a profundidad un detalle muy
importante que es porque el acetonas no
pueden hacer puentes de hidrógeno con
otras cetonas no sé si te estés
preguntando eso
por aquí tenemos dos cetonas y estas
cetonas definitivamente tienen
hidrógenos que este carbono de aquí
tiene tres hidrógenos ok pero esto es
importante este hidrógeno está enlazado
con un carbono no con un oxígeno y el
carbono es menos electro negativo que el
oxígeno entonces no se forma un dipolo
tan fuerte como se necesita para hacer
un puente de hidrógeno así es que
definitivamente no se pueden hacer
puentes de hidrógeno entre dos zonas
para hacer un puente de hidrógeno el
hidrógeno necesita estar enlazado con
algo muy electro negativo como el flúor
oxígeno o nitrógeno ahora aunque los
puentes de hidrógeno no sean posibles
entre dos zonas si son posibles entre un
acetona y una molécula de agua aunque
hay aquí tenemos un puente de hidrógeno
y entonces por lo menos la acetona si va
a ser soluble en agua
exactamente lo mismo va a suceder con
aldehídos y cetonas pequeños el problema
con los aldehídos y cetonas grandes es
que conforme hacemos cada vez más grande
el grupo al kilo conforme aumentamos el
número de carbonos enlazados con el
grupo carbón y lo estamos aumentando
cosas no polares estamos disminuyendo el
carácter polar de esta molécula entonces
entre más carbonos agreguemos entre más
parte de la molécula sea no polar menos
soluble va a ser la molécula